georgia senator david perdue you know um
you got so close but this is
those are the rules talk about the
governor and this and
the secretary of state and all these
votes we're finding in georgia well
first of all
sean i i have to tell you i think
president trump has every right to
demand that
every legal vote be counted and every
illegal vote be removed and that
that's what's at stake here we're in the
fight of our life here this is uh
we're the last line of defense in
georgia that's what makes every vote
count right now in this if we win
georgia we
save america frankly that's why i need
your viewers to help us at purdue senate
dot com to chip in a few bucks to help
us but
right now we're in the process of trying
to find out we just found a few thousand
votes that have disappeared for the last
week and a half
that just showed up and now president
trump is within ten thousand votes of
of biden in georgia and i'm right now
ten thousand even though i won by two
points i'm still about ten thousand
votes away from the fifty percent
uh margin that you have to get in
georgia or going to this nine week
runoff
well you know i lived four years in
georgia i
love the state love the people the state
and
i cannot believe what's unfolding how is
it even
possible that this could happen two
weeks after an election
and when you identify the differences
between you and your opponent and what
these two senate races mean
are the people of georgia keenly aware
do they understand how big this is this
is it
all eyes on georgia
well kelly lefler and i are the
republican candidates for these two
seats and as i said before the majority
of the senate comes down to these two
seats it's our job to make sure
that the people of georgia know just as
what's at stake look we know what the
democrats want to do you just
highlighted most of it but they want
illegal immigrants to vote
they want to defund the police they want
to take away our private health
insurance
and they want to stack the court that's
not what our
government has always been about it's
been about checks and balances and what
schumer said the other day he said we
win georgia we change america aoc said
look we're all about we want to win
those two seats because we do not want
to negotiate she wants a green new deal
without compromise
and so we've got to make sure the people
in georgia
turn out again if we do we win we've
already beaten the democrats 52 and a
half percent sean of georgia
voters rejected this liberal uh left
move that the democrats are trying to
perpetrate
and i think that's a big sign that
nobody's talking about i hope the peop
are you talking to the people in georgia
and how are they reacting to this
unfolding mess there and do they
in other words do you s is there a
ground swell of anger that is going to
push people to the polls or maybe they
throw their hands up why bother after
i'm watching this
adam shift show well it could it could
go either way i think there's a
there are a lot of voters who are trump
voters in georgia who are disheartened
they're angry because they think the
president did not get a fair shake in
georgia we know there are improprieties
in georgia then they're going to be
they're
being investigated right now what we're
trying to do is make sure
that those same opportunities for
impropriety are not there for the
january 5th
election i mean this is what we've got
to do is convince people that their vote
is going to be counted and it's going to
be accounted
for accurately and so that's the biggest
thing our job right now is to make sure
that the base
gets out in votes and knows how
important this is look this is the fight
of our lives
sean as you've said over and over this
week if we lose these seats we may not
get another shot at this because schumer
will get a perpetual majority
and we won't be able to break through
there when he adds two new states and
four new democratic seats
this is the fight of our lives to make
sure that we continue to have a balanced
approach to government in america
senator i can't i cannot even put enough
emphasis
on on how accurate you are all right
senator perdue we'll keep following it i
hope the people of georgia
the country need you badly